bonjour à tous
beaucoup aux étudiants des arts et
métiers d'avoir organisé cette rencontre
alors la question que j'aimerais
partager avec vous aujourd'hui c'est à
quoi ça sert la culture à quoi ça sert
l'art à quoi ça sert aujourd'hui à
l'heure d'internet d'aller voir encore
des oeuvres dans des musées d'aller voir
encore des spectacles sur scène de lire
des livres et de passer du temps à versa
j'aimerais vous poser une question si
vous aviez love qui a derrière moi
bernicat dans votre salon est-ce que
vous invitez votre voisin pour la
découvrir
et est-ce que vous lui parleriez du prix
à laquelle vous l'avez acheté pendant
deux heures
c'est mal polis en fait je ne sais pas
pour ça que vous avez mis guernica dans
votre salon c'est à dire que justifier
la culture par l'économie ce serait
peut-être aussi impoli la culture ça
peut être une source d'attractivité ça
peut mettre en valeur un territoire ça
peut créer des externalités positives
comme on dit en économie clé du tourisme
créé des nuits d'hôtel mais au final est
ce que c'est vraiment ça donc
aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie de vous
parler de la culture du point de vue de
l'économie les limites de la culture
s'est pas seulement l'économie
vous invitez votre voisin mais guernica
dans votre salon est-ce que c'est son
avis qui serait le plus important est ce
que vous pensez que avoir garni qu'à
dans votre salon ça peut rendre heureux
votre voisin est pas forcément vous
l'avez surtout acheté pour vous parce
que vous aviez un rapport avec cette
oeuvre
donc j'ai pas envie non plus parler la
culture aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
uniquement sociales
certes ça peut faire du bien mais je
pense pas que ce soit le premier rapport
qu'on puisse avoir avec la culture donc
à quoi ça sert
je sais pas en fait vous raconter cette
anecdote de guernica la première fois
que j'ai vu ce tableau au musée reina
sofia à madrid
je l'avais vu pendant mon enfance on
reproduction temps des livres
ça m'avait pas fait grand chose et quand
je suis arrivé devant ce tableau avec
les dimensions du tableau qui est un
tableau assez assez magistrale parce
qu'il fait près de cinq mètres de base
je vais rester presque une demi-heure
sans parler c'est à dire que la parole a
été absolument couper
j'ai senti une émotion qui mentait en
moi doucement doucement m'envahir et
j'ai eu l'impression d'un seul coup
tombé amoureux rencontrer quelqu'un
avoir une vraie rencontre une rencontre
unique dans sa vie je crois que c'est ce
rapport là d'un seul coup un rapport à
la fois unique parce que c'est d'une
personne à une oeuvre et en même temps
ça rapport universel parce que chaque
personne qui passera devant guernica
aura cette même relation absolument
intime à une oeuvre d'art qui lui
parlera en sont fort le plus intérieure
c'est quelque chose extrêmement
mystérieux c'est que l'oeuvre d'art ce à
la fois quelque chose d'universel et d'
absolument singulier
en pourquoi guernica ça m'a parlé
puisque mon grand-père était anarchiste
espagnol et il a fui la dictature de
franco
et quand il est arrivé en france sans
rien en traversant les pyrénées avec ma
grand mère et mon père qui avait un
temps à l'époque la seule chose qu'ils
avaient quand ils sont arrivés en france
c'était
l'allemand leur culture ce qu'il est
constitué et je crois que c'est pour çà
guernica m'a parlé manière très très
très forte
c'est que d'un seul coup j'ai vu que un
artiste picasso avait réussi à rendre
quelque chose qui appartenait à mon
histoire individuelle manière
extrêmement forte et d'un seul coup ça
crée un symbole s'arrêter le temps et
qu'il arrivait à représenter des choses
mystérieuses que je ressentais depuis
longtemps et sur lesquels je n'arrivais
pas à mettre de mots la culture on dit
souvent que c'est quelque chose
d'élitiste c'est quelque chose auquel on
n'a pas droit
c'est quelque chose comme une richesse
moi je crois qu'au contraire l'art et la
culture c'est ce qu'on a quand on n'a
plus rien c'est à dire c'est ce qui nous
reste
quand on est dépossédé de tout
républicain espagnol
quand la dictature de franco a été mise
en place il ya une histoire absolument
incroyable ils ont décidé pour sauver la
république de rassembler toutes les
offres du bras d'eau tout le mobilier
tous les tableaux on voit ici les
conservateurs en train de ranger les
différents tableaux et pour fuir l'armée
franquiste
ils ont fait sept camions ils sont
partie de nuit avec ce qu'on appelle
trésor national
c'est en 1937 pour essayer de fuir la
dictature franquiste et de sauver
l'identité de l'espagne et l'identité de
l'espagne c'était la somme des tableaux
la somme des sculptures la somme du
mobilier on est ici dans une école
d'arts et métiers qui avait été
constituée pendant des décennies et des
décennies pour pouvoir constituer
l'identité de la république c'est à dire
le bien commun donc je crois que la
culture avant tout quand on se pose
cette question là quand la dictature
repousse les limites
de ce qui appartient à une république on
s'aperçoit que c'est l'ensemble des
oeuvres qui ont été produits par une
communauté humaine et dont on reconnaît
qu'elle crée une identité à un moment
donné ces sept camions ils sont partis
du trésor national a été caché à
barcelone dans un château pendant à peu
près une dizaine de mois et ensuite les
camions sont repartis sont allés se
réfugier à genève et à l'unesco on a
caché le trésor national la république
espagnole jusqu'à la fin de la dictature
franquiste que ce à quoi sert la culture
c'est au final qui est le plus précieux
et qui tient à un moment donné à ce que
les hommes décide de l'accorder de la
valeur et ça on les prouve qu'en
politiquement les choses vont plutôt mal
derrière moi on voit une photo très très
émouvant du régime nazi qui avait décidé
de brûler des livres dans des
bibliothèques
certains ouvrages été condamné 11 et des
bûchers public et on organisait des
grands feux et on brûlait toute une
partie de la culture ce qu'on estimait
qu' une partie de la culture n'avait
plus n'avait plus le droit d'exister
aujourd'hui quand on dit quand on
censure des artistes quand on attaque
des formes canton anton condamne
certains types de cultures de quelle
forme quelle soit qu'elles viennent de
très loin à ce moment là on remet en
question le bien commun en miroir
et que cette cette horrible images nazim
j'aimerais vous parler d'un très beau
roman qui s'appelle fahrenheit de ray
bradbury qui raconte comment est ce que
qui est en scène en fait une société où
on décide de brûler de brûler tous les
livres et il ya une résistance qui
s'organise avec des hommes qui décident
temps destine mans d'apprendre chacun un
livre par coeur et il crée la communauté
des hommes livrent ils se cachent
de ce régime autoritaire et chaque jour
un homme livre récite un livre qui l'a
appris par coeur pour les autres
effectivement la culture c'est ce qu'on
a quand on n'a plus rien et ceux dont ce
qu'il faut protéger chacun pour soi ce
qu'on peut partager avec les autres une
fois qu'on a appris pour soi-même à
protéger par exemple un livre et c'est
un bien commun qu'on doit qu'on doit
défendre avec une politique de la
culture c'est-à-dire considérer que ce
qui nous appartient on bien commun ça
doit être protégé donc il faut faire des
musées il faut faire des théâtres il
faut considérer que tout ce qu'on a en
commun doit être protégé là vous avez
une très belle image de d'andré malraux
qui une série de photos d'oeuvres d'art
devant lui on dit souvent que internet a
été créé par l'armée américaine moi je
soutiens aujourd'hui devant vous qu'en
fait ce andré malraux qu'inventer
internet
il avait l'idée de de créer ce qu'on
appelle un musée imaginaire malraux lui
par part du postulat qu il ya des gens
qui ont existé il ya des objets qui ont
existé mais que l'oeuvre d'aramon donné
en représentant soit les gens
représentant des scènes en représentant
des situations c'est ce qui a permis à
la réalité de faire une métamorphose de
se transformer et toutes ses séries de
métamorphose dont on garde les images ça
permet de créer un gigantesque musée
imaginaire en fait que la culture c'est
ce vaste musée imaginaire qu'on doit
tous protégés ensemble
j'aimerais vous parler maintenant tu
d'expérience qu'on a eu à valenciennes
qui interroge ce lien individuelles
qu'on peut avoir à l'oeuvre d'art ce que
vous me direz on sait bien mais où
est-ce que ça commence comment est-ce
qu'on peut commencer à être sensibles à
une oeuvre d'art et avoir ce rapport
individuel ce qu on aura beau ouvrir des
musées ouvrir des débats de faire des
belles programmations
quand est ce qu'une personne dit j'y ai
droit c'est fait pour moi est ce que
j'ai le droit de rentrer dans un théâtre
est ce que j'ai le droit de rentrer dans
un musée en 2010 tron je suis arrivé à
valenciennes pour prendre la direction
du phénix on s'est dit ben
ou que des personnes aient le droit
sentent qu'elles faisaient le droit
d'accéder à la culture
on va pas leur dire c'est bien c'est
génial vous devez voir ça sinon vous
allez pète mais au contraire on va
favoriser la pratique sensible la
pratique artistique
c'est à dire on se met souvent un
plateau ont fait un atelier sur fernand
teulié de danse ont fait un atelier de
création plastique et c'est à partir de
cette expérience sensible en rencontrant
un artiste professionnel que là il se
passe quelque chose qui se transforme en
nous dans ce rapport très intime et donc
là on voit une photo d'un très beau
projet qui s'appelait dogora on a
associé 400 enfants et 200 adultes qui
devait créer une grande fresque musicale
tous ensemble c'était pour des gens qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude de chanter
donc on a recruté des enfants dans tous
les quartiers de la vie des quartiers
défavorisés des quartiers un peu plus
favorisés mais l'idée c'était d'avoir
une grande mixité sociale avec des
personnes qui n'étaient pas forcément
intéressés par l'art ou des enfants qui
n'allait pas forcément au conservatoire
et là il ya une jeune fille qui
s'appelle mélodies s'amendent pas etc à
participer pendant deux ans à des
ateliers autour de cette grande fresque
musicale et elle a mis deux ans avant de
sentir le droit de venir nous voir et et
nous poser la question suivante c'est
est-ce que moi qui habite à
chasse-royale un quartier d'une pauvreté
terrible à valenciennes mais russell au
foyer jamais jamais travaillé situation
économique terrible
est-ce que moi mélodies qui vient de ce
quartier là est ce que je peux
m'inscrire en classe à horaires aménagés
musique au collège et là je me suis dit
waouh c'est parce que j'imaginais jeune
femme je devine a mis deux ans avant de
se sentir le droit de nous poser cette
question là est ce qu'elle peut rentrer
dans une école de la république pour
avoir accès à un enseignement artistique
c'est là où on fait un retour en arrière
et on se dit oh deux ans à un individu
un jeune être une jeune fille qui
commence à vie pour avoir ce rapport
intime à l'art et osé faire le premier
pas alors sa mère lui avait dit c'est
pas fait pour toi c'est trop cher ça va
nous coûter de l'argent et après donc on
s'est débrouillé avec le directeur du
conservatoire pour la faire veut la
faire changer de collège à faire venir
avec sa soeur pour qu'elle ait le droit
à suivre des enseignements classes à
horaires aménagés musique donc la
culture ça sert à transformer l'individu
à se dire qu'on peut changer qu'on a le
droit d'aller au delà des limites qu'on
se fixe à soi même parce qu'on dit c'est
pas fait pour soi mais c'est un
processus qui est extrêmement long et
c'est un processus qui doit absolument
s'appuyer sur l'éducation sont l'école
et sur ce rapport là à la sensibilité
qui doit être absolument protéger par
l'école
j'aimerais finir par cette dernière
image
cette question de à quoi ça sert la
culture je crois que ça sert aussi à
comprendre les autres là en fait la
personne que vous voyez ce jeune homme
qui pourrait être un étudiant des arts
et métiers c'est claude lévi strauss qui
était jeune et qui a des idées
après avoir passé son agrégation de
philosophie en france de partir à la
découverte des indiens d'amazonie et là
on le voit en confrontation avec avec
avec un jeune indien haut débit strauss
est parti là bas en dix ans ces gens
qu'on estime tête des bons sauvages
comment est ce qu'ils pensent comment
est-ce qu'ils réfléchissent comment est
ce qu'ils vivent ensemble et codevi
strauss qui a inventé tout
l'anthropologie moderne qui a
révolutionné la comble à la conception
même de la culture s'est aperçu que les
mécanismes de penser des indiens le
rapport aux divinités le rapport à la
famille le rapport au quotidien étaient
organisations culturelles aussi complexe
aussi raffiné que nous occidentaux bédié
de chrétienté qui imaginions la part du
très colonial être avoir un rapport de
supériorité par rapport à ccc tribut à
ces tribus indiennes
ce que je crois que ça sert à ça avant
tout la culture c'est essayer de
découvrir les différences de l'autre des
analyses et pour essayer de voir ce qui
nous ce qui nous rassemble et comment
est-ce qu'on se ressemble et comment
est-ce que de nos différences on peut
trouver une ou bien d'une humanité
humanité commune
merci